[Music]
washington dc michael's on the line hey
michael what's up
hey guys thanks for having me on i
appreciate it sure how can we help
hey uh so my wife and i are 65 000 in
debt right now mostly credit cards and
some from a car um and
right now when we've looked at our
budget we put it on a an excel sheet and
at the end of the day we have more going
uh in the negative than coming in uh
positive to spend on our daily needs
okay and we we we're we're kind of at a
loss right now we're
financially we're scared for our future
of what we're supposed to do and we're
so much in the negative that we can't
even get to the positive i can't even
okay i'm trying to follow your baby
steps of saving up a thousand dollars
and
i can't even do that because i'm in the
negative every month
what do y'all do for a living
uh i'm a teacher and my wife works for
the government
what do you teach
elementary school okay good okay
um
and so what's your household income
about 100 time a year okay
how much do you owe on the car
uh
oh 17 000.
okay
well i hear the stress in your voice and
i have been there
uh you make good money you live in an
expensive area so 110 doesn't go that
far
it sounds like you ought to be able to
live on that but you're in washington dc
it's expensive
um how much is your house payment or
rent
uh it's about two thousand a month
okay
that's high but it's not what's killing
you so where's the rest of money go yeah
your money's there's a leak somewhere
how much do you all eat out all the time
well credit cards are what are you
buying with the credit cards
it's some past credit card usage
you only have 40 000 in credit card debt
yeah
it's
the payments are
between the each of them they about 200
300 a month
yeah
okay
okay um
here's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes it sounds like there is
uh you are being killed death by a
thousand cuts i don't hear a major
hole in the side of the boat i hear lots
of little leaks
from years of doing budgets with people
that's what i hear
okay
um so the little leaks sound like this
you're gonna go on a scorched earth
thing and turn this thing around because
you're stuck the good news is you're
sick and tired of being stuck i can hear
it in your voice you're a little bit
scared a little bit desperate a little
bit pissed off that's a really good mix
for changing things because you're going
to have to get radical
so here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to start a tutoring business
tomorrow you can make 50 to 100 an hour
tutoring elementary school kids in the
afternoons i've had people get out of
debt doing tutoring that were teachers
all the time i hear it all the time and
there's such a need of people like you
to be able to do this and
then you're not going to see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there you guys eat out too much you
spend too freaking much money outside
the walls of your home
you don't need to go on vacation period
until you get this mess cleaned up you
need to get the credit cards out tonight
light a candle and have a plastic
surgery ceremony and chop them all up
into little bitty stinking pieces and
you're never borrowing money again for
anything in it with the extra income and
the reduced outgo if you can have you
gotten a big tax refund
no okay if you can't find some money in
dialing this thing down with all of that
you're going to sell the car but the car
is not your problem it just might be a
little bit of the solution a seventeen
thousand dollar car debt on a hundred
and ten thousand dollar income is not
good but it's not drowning you and i'm
talking to a guy who sounds like he's
drowning that's right
what is this split split me your your
salaries what do you make versus your
wife
uh my wife is about 60 and about 50.
okay
there is a hard moment and nobody likes
to talk about this there is a hard
moment when you look at your total life
you're teaching government work and you
look at how y'all are scraping by you're
scratching your claw and you ask
yourselves
is this where we have to live is this
where we want to live is there another
place that we would be interested in
doing life and my wife and i have had
that conversation it's hard it's
gut-wrenching
and it also was life-giving ultimately
right so some of those big existential
questions you can have on top of the
grinding and the clawing that you're
doing to get out of this thing to get
unstuck
so hang on kelly's going to pick up and
i'm going to sign you up for financial
peace university in every dollar the
premium map and we will show you hand in
glove how to do exactly what you need to
do to get this mess straightened up
we'll walk with you brother hold on